Hilla incognita is an area that was not
charted before or not visited before not
seen before Shalom my name is Gabriele
Eden and I'm the inventor of the pooka I
had a neighbor who was a
gastroenterologist and he told me the
new hinder scopes he cannot get into the
small intestinal tract this five to six
meters was really unknown uncharted the
capsule was able to see it very clearly
it is a small television studio it has a
miniature camera it has the illumination
and a small transmitter to an outside
recorder the procedure it does not
require any hospitalization you come to
the Year clinic you swallow the capsule
put on the belt put on your jacket and
go to work by now we manufacture 1.7
million capsules the cost is extremely
small as compared with the endoscope
some people told me that the window will
be obscured by dirt we found out that
the small intestinal tract once he would
avoid eating for two hours is full of
water and you see beautiful images we
say that in this specific case Murphy
who was asleep the capsule in his
assemble here in Israel in the town of
Jacques nom I am very glad to have the
opportunity to offer employment to local
people I was born here so I didn't
choose it it was chosen for me
you